Virtualization is an old idea.
It originated in the 60s at IBM when
the norm of computing was that there
were a few large mainframe computers
that were shared by many users and
many business services.
In order to concurrently run a very
diverse workloads on the same physical
hardware, without requiring that
a single operating system be used for
all of the o- applications for
all of the possible purposes,
it was necessary to come up with a model
where multiple operating systems
can concurrently be deployed
on the same hardware platform.
With virtualization,
each of the operating systems that are
deployed on the same physical platform
has an illusion that it actually owns
the underlying hardware resources.
Or at least some smaller
portion of them.
For instance,
the operating system may think that
it owns some smaller amount of memory
compared to the memory that's actually
available on the physical machine.
Each operating system together with its
applications as well as the virtual
resources that it pings at us is called
a virtual machine, or VM for short.
This represents a virtual
machine because it is distinct
from the physical machine that is
natively managed by some software stack.
Virtual machines are often referred
to as guests such as guest VMs or
also referred to as domains,
like a guest domain for instance.
To support the coexistence of multiple
virtual machines on the same physical
machine, require some underlying
functionality in order to deal with
the allocation and the management of
the real, physical hardware resources.
In addition,
it's necessary to provide some
isolation guarantees across these VMs.
This is provided by
the virtualization layer,
that is refered to as virtual
machine monitor or hypervisor, also.
There are multiple ways in
which the functionality,
that's required by the virtualization
layer, can be designed and implemented.
And in this lesson we will describe
some of the key virtualization
related techniques.